did you ever build on the research or
look at the research of ning lee or i
don't know how to pronounce this but pod
kid litenov's super conductors
evgeny potlet
um
he
is a very interesting i i read some of
his papers for example i read the one on
impulse generator
and the way that he used these
incredibly high voltages this discharge
i think he used a marks generator or
something of that nature to to provide
this impulse gravitational wave again
i
if you look at the pious effect they
never used any of those ideas
this came directly again from the heavy
side version of maxwell equation and i i
apologize for sounding repetitive but
that's exactly where it came from and
that's what convinced dr sheehy because
it came from fundamentals
things that he was accustomed to and
acquainted with
i was able to convince him
that's why he said what he said
let me forgive my rudimentary question
remember i'm not an engineer i'm more on
the theoretical end if anything what's
the difference between a pulse and an
impulse
i myself would would
to me
and it sounds the same almost uh
maybe
an impulse could be the effect
of a pulsed action
one could be the effect of the other
possible
but sometimes i'll tell you the truth
language confuses me
maybe maybe because english is
not you know my first language what is
your personal romania
i was born in romania i came here when i
was 13 and a half years old and by the
way
uh
romanian
name which means
long live the romanian people long live
romania
nothing without god
i am uh i'm religious
always have been
but mostly since my mother passed away
from stage four liver cancer
and
it
you need something to i
strengthen you
trust me i know i pray a whole lot
and
i never i would never
try to bring my beliefs to anyone else i
think
i think religion is a personal
it shouldn't be laughed at that
that's all
so you had a transition of work you went
from the naval air systems command to
naval strategic systems program and do
you like your new positions better
um
actually
i cannot say exactly where i work now
but i had moved on from the space
strategic systems programs uh the navy
to the space force
just new opportunities
uh
new ideas to i'm an engineer so i like
to
do practical things
so when i'm presented with a new
opportunity sometimes
i pick up and go
not necessarily with my
the the location of my uh
abode
but with
just a new opportunity new faces new
ideas new
new possibilities
that's always intrigued me
maybe that's why
this work spans
so many physics domains from condensed
metaphysics to general relativity to
quantum gravity and so forth
so yeah
i like to learn
i never stop learning
i think when you stop learning
something in you dies or it atrophies
you should always be
learning new things
now i'm not necessarily saying
learn all things in all domains i
for example if i was to go into the
medical field i
this is why i hold you in tremendous
esteem
for example the word the how you were
able to read on the work of dr carl
frist and this is
i do not think i could have read those
papers so my head down
i barely read them so
now
that's
even dr fristin at one point said
you know you you understand these
amazingly well